[Musique]
bonsoir bonsoir à toutes et à tous
Bienvenue c'est sens publici on est
ensemble pour 90 minutes de débat de
chronique et de reportage et c'est une
édition spéciale que je vous propose ce
soir consacré au discours de politique
générale de Gabriel hatal devant le
Sénat le Premier ministre souhaite
qu'une loi sur la décentralisation soit
présenté d'ici à la fin de l'année il
demande au LR de ne pas bloquer le texte
sur la fin de vie et la Constitution
alisation de l'interruption volontaire
de grossesse il veut aussi donner la
main au maire dans l'attribution des
logements sociaux c'est un discours en
partie tournée vers les territoires dans
lequel Gabriel Atal a aussi détaillé les
annonces faites hier notamment en
direction des agriculteurs nos
agriculteurs souffrent ils incarnent
tous les défis d'une France qui doute
ils sont le visage du travail et du
dévouement ils ne connaissent ni
vacances ni véritable repos et pourtant
leur rémunération n'est pas toujours à
la hauteur de leur engagement à la
hauteur de ce qu'ils apportent à notre
pays alors oui tous les Français des
classes moyennes se reconnaissent en eux
tous ces Français qui ne peuvent compter
que sur leur travail mais doivent
compter chaque euro à la fin du mois
l'autorité la marque de fabrique l'une
des marques de fabrique de Gabriel Atal
va-t-elle aussi s'appliquer à la colère
des agriculteurs sa feuille de route
accentue-elle encore le virage à droite
du second quinquena Macron les classes
moyennes à qui le premier ministre
s'adresse vont-elles se mobiliser aux
élections européennes le 9 juin prochain
on en débattra dans cette émission
d'abord avec nos experts puis avec nos
invités 100 % politiques quatre
sénateurs qui nous diront s'ils ont été
convaincus par le nouveau locataire de
Matignon mais d'abord le récit de cette
après-midi de Gabriel hatal au Sénat
avec Mathias
araez sous la coupole du Palais du
Luxembourg et face à une autre majorité
Gabriel hatal a prononcé une nouvelle
version de son discours de politique
générale 1 heure et dem le Premier
ministre a déroulé son programme de
gouvernement face à des sénateurs pour
certains dubitatifs l'illusion
macroniste du social libéralisme de 2017
aura duré un printemps vous n'avez fait
que semer les graines de la colère qui
sont en train de germer sur le terraau
de vos choix de société et votre
vocabulaire guerrier n'est que le signe
avant tout d'une grande faiblesse
idéologiquement opposé à
Bruno retill montre lui aussi
l'hostilité de son groupe au chef de
l'exécutifur mais n'attendez pas de nous
que nous devenions macronistes vous
dites j'ai confiance nous n'avons pas
confiance nous avons appris à nous
méfier aujourd'hui il faudra que cette
confiance vous puissiez la reconstruire
parce qu'aujourd'hui le sentiment qui
domine ici c'est précisément la défiance
à l'inverse Hervé Marseille chef de fil
de l'autre composante de la majorité
sénatoriale l'Union centriste
appelle à la responsabilité de chacun
cette responsabilité elle pèse sur vos
épaules elle pèse aussi sur nos épaules
si vous échouez si nous échouons vous et
nous savons qui arbitrera nos différents
en 2027 et alors il sera trop tard pour
pleurer sur le lait renversé un sénat
qui ne fera donc pas plus de cadeaux à
gabrielal qu'à éisabeth borne et sans
qui cela a été rappelé la réforme des
retraites et la loi immigration n'aurit
pu être sur le du Titanic Gabriel Atal
peut-il compter sur le Sénat pour
réformer c'est l'un des thèmes de notre
débat avec Florent vadiot bonsoir
bienvenue vous êtes le président de
l'éée enseignant à à scienp chriselle
craplelet directrice BVA opinion bonsoir
et bienvenue Benjamin Morel bienvenue à
vous bonsoir constitutionnaliste maître
de conférence en droit public Paris de
Panthéon Assas et vous publiez la France
en miette aux éditions du SER Mathieu
croissant d'au éditorialiste politique
bonsoir Mathieu bonsoir à tous un
Gabriel àal plus calme peut-être moins
tourbillonnant euh dans son discours de
politique générale au Sénat en
comparaison de celui de l'Assemblée
nationale hier Florent est-ce que c'est
la naissence d'un style si on parle de
la forme un peu pour commencer bah quand
on change de style d'un coup sur l'autre
c'est qu'on en a pas euh non il y a
indéiablement pour son jeune âge du
talent chez Gabriel Atal ensuite il y a
pas une noovation extraordinaire qui
ferait dire qu'il est à nul autre pareil
la précocité effectivement mais on a
connu d'autres min ministre précoce
Valérie giscardestin en son temps était
extrêmement précoce et et autrement plus
brillant peut-être on le verra dans les
débats en tout cas comme ministre du
Budget il est clair que valerrie
cardesttin avait le dessus le style
Gabriel atthal c'est surtout un style de
communication plus que de rhthorique et
et avec des marqueurs politiques qui qui
sont là donc c'est un style de
communication qui en fait reprend les
anciennes du
macronisme en se dépouillant globalement
de tout ce qui faisait les clin d'œils à
la gauche donc c'est une nouveauté dans
un dans un macronisme déjà connu
Christel crappel c'est dans un contexte
quand même particulier pour un discours
de politique générale en en pleine crise
agricole la la popularité de Gabriel
Atal c'est pour ça que en grande partie
pour ça qu'Emmanuel Macron l'a nommé à à
matigon est-ce qu'elle est soluble dans
la crise agricole vous voyez ce que je
veux dire pendant combien de temps
peut-elle résister à ce à ce conflit bah
c'est tout l'enjeu ça va on va ça va
dépendre un petit peu de sa manière
d'agir de répondre pour l'instant quand
même il incarne un peu ce volontarisme
en tout cas dans les il se déplace ça
c'est des choses quand même qui marquent
les Français qui sont perçus assez
positivement il est resté que quelques
mois à l'éducation nationale il a
grandement marqué les esprits par
quelques paroles par quelques
déplacements donc voilà ça peut
fonctionner à court terme maintenant à
long terme faut voir comment évolue
cette crise faut voir aussi les réponse
qui va apporter sur les principaux
sujets de de préoccupation des Français
on sait hein les premiers ministres même
quand ils commencent un peu populaire il
chutent très très vite à voir là pour la
spécificité de de Gabriel on suivra ça
évidemment dans les dans les prochains
jours et même dans quelques minutes il y
a déjà quelques sondages sur la la les
Français qui ont entendu ou qui ont eu
le le retour de ce que Gabriel Atal
avait proncé dans son discours de de
politique générale sont-ils convaincus
ou pas on va en parler dans dans dans
une seconde Benjamin Morel on parle
souvent de marque politique on peut dire
que Rachid hadti est une marque
politique Emmanuel Macron a réussi à
attirer dans dans dans son gouvernement
est-ce que Gabriel hatal est en train de
devenir une marque politique pour
l'instant c'est trop tôt pour le dire il
est vrai qu'il y a un style à t il y a
une façon je dirais et bien de
communiquer cette façon de communiquer
peut permettre et bien de donner le
sentiment qu'on a une forme de dynamique
mais il faut pas non plus se mentir
aujourd'hui les difficultés qui sont
celles devant Gabriel à tal sont des
difficultés extrêmement importantes
d'abord parce qu'il fait son discours de
politique général à 3 semaines de sa
nomination en pleine crise agricole et
donc les grandes annonces quand bien
même il y en a eu hier et bien passe un
petit peu sous les radars l'autre
élément c'est que vous n'avez pas de
majorité parlementaire et le discours
d'hier n'a probablement pas ramené une
partie de cette majorité parlementaire
au berkaille et qui plus est il y a plus
de finance il y a il y a pas en tout cas
d'argent pour éteindre les des incendis
sociaux donc malgré tout vous pouvez
tenter de jouer les pompiers mais c'est
sans eau dans la barique et donc ce
faisant vous pouvez être dans la
communication il y a une communication
qui est en effet bien rodée mais face à
des professions comme les agriculteurs
organisé avec des revendications posées
puis un vrai malette par ailleurs et
bien ces artifices de communication ne
fonctionnent guère et là on voit bien
qu'aujourd'hui malgré le discours
politique général d'hier malgré le
discours devant le Sénat aujourd'hui les
agriculteurs ils regardent devant ils
regardent vers l'Élysée ils regardent
vers Bruxelles bref ils attendent
qu'Emmanuel Macron fasse bouger les
choses au niveau européen ce qui montre
que là-dessus la marge de manœuvre du
Premier ministre est en grande partie
surfite et pour certains entre il
regardent vers r c'est l'un des enjeux
de cette de cette fin d'après-midi et de
cette soirée je vous pr un sondage alors
c'est pas c'est pas votre institut mais
c'est odxa question globalement lors de
ce discours avez-vous trouver gabiral
plutôt convaincant ou pas 58 % ne sont
pas convaincus et 41 % sont convaincus
et alors c'est intéressant si on regarde
par famille politique euh bon les
renaissances 87 % convaincu mais ensuite
on a 58 % de sympathisants LR qui sont
convaincus ensuite 48 % de sympathisants
écologistes après le PS LFI et le RN
comment vous analysez C notamment le le
le le soutien affiché encore par des
sympathisants LR B c'est ce qu'on voit
même dans sa structure de popularité il
marque beaucoup de points auprès des
sympathisants LR et ça montre qu'il peut
y avoir un certains décalage entre les
personnes qui se disent proches deslr et
les politiques au sein de LR que ce soit
à l'Assemblée nationale ou au Sénat pour
l'instant dans l'opinion même quand on
est sympathisant LR on apprécie plutôt
Gabriel Atal mais ça c'est encore le
bénéfice pardon de vous interrompre de
de son passage même bref à l'éducation
nationale ou c'est aussi un peu les les
les les premiers pas de de Gabriel c'est
un peu tout je pense que ça ces premiers
pas ont confirmé ça il l'avait déjà au
moment de de sa nomination et même plus
généralement les sympathisants à l'air
restent quand même assez bienveillants à
l'égard même d'Emmanuel Macron ils sont
sont beaucoup moins dans l'opposition
que ne le sont encore une fois les
députés ou les sénateurs LR alors parmi
les Mathieu voulez intervenir non c'est
pas très étonnant qu'il soit soutenu par
les par les
sympathisants est quand même un
gouvernement qui est composé plus de la
majorité par d'ancien UMP d'ancien LR
une Sarkozi comme Rachid hadti il a
coché beaucoup de cases qui était sur le
signe de l'autorité qui est plutôt une
valeur partagé par cet électorat et puis
il s'inscrit dans une politique et un
discours présidentiel qui vire de plus
en plus à droite mais luimême on l'a
entendu hier donc oui en quand on entend
Bruno rotillot le président du groupe LR
ici au Sénat ou d'autres ou d'autres
députés ou représentant du du parti
c'est pas le même son peut-être la
question qu'il faut se poser c'est
est-ce que les dirigeants LR plaisent à
l'électorat l on l'a vu à la dernière
présidentielle et au dernière
législative que c'était pas forcément le
cas effectivement alors autre réaction
politique cette fois-ci à gauche Boris
Vallot le président du groupe socialiste
à l'Assemblée nationale qui voit en
Gabriel le porte-parole d'Emmanuel
Macron il est son porte-parole
l'inspiration il est vrai et
sarkoziste mais j'avais depuis longtemps
avec la réforme de l'assurance chômage
avec la réforme des retraites avec la
loi immigration compris et la
composition du gouvernement est venue le
confirmer que au fond Emmanuel Macron
était l'exécuteur testamentaire de
Nicolas Sarkozi donc nous en sommes d'un
certaine manière là c'est un discours du
passé on aurait aimé une réinvention de
la part d'un Premier ministre qui est le
plus jeune de la 5e de la 5e République
mais il est le visage jeune au fond du
vieux monde le visage jeune du Vieux
Monde certain V même du jusqu'à parler
d'un discours réac qu'est-ce que vous
êtes sur cette ligne Florent adadiot
incontestablement il n'a pas cultivé
l'indistinction puisque il n a pas un
clin d'œil à la gauche pas une volonté
d'attirer des suffrages de gauche en
tout cas il est clair que dans la
constitution d'une majorité Gabriel ATA
a fait un choix et que ce choix il l'a
martelé et l'ensemble du discours de ce
point de vue-là et les annonces qui ont
été euh mis en en en en lumière elles
sont extrêmement éloquentes sur le
logement social sur la question de la
location sur la question du RSA il y a
tout de même pour le coup des irritants
absolus pour la gauche et qui sont dans
la dans le droitfil de ce que la
majorité sénatoriale de droite prône et
ce qui avait été d'ailleurs la France du
travail que Nicolas Sarkozi avait voulu
marteler également donc oui il y a il y
a une forme d'orthodoxie de droite avec
des thèmes récurrents le travail la
sécurité et l'autorité Benjamin vous
avez commencé à l'évoquer mais ça peut
encore plus fragiliser fragilis disait
j'y arrive sa majorité déjà relative à
l'Assemblée assez probablement hein
Florien vadiillot il disait qu' dit
qu'il fait la il a fait le choix d'une
majorité il a fait le deuil d'une
majorité je dirais c'est-à-dire que
l'ile gauche exactement l'ile gauche on
l'oublie parce qu'en effet je suis assez
d'accord à part peut-être quelques
éléments sur les réquisitions de
logement vacan il y a quand même aucun
signe envoyé à la gauche de sa majorité
histoire de penser quelque peu les PL la
loi immigration et de la composition du
gouvernement on verra les secrétaire
d'État et les ministres délégués mais à
ce stadelà quand même et ben on ne donne
donne aucun signe et donc il y a pas de
raison de penser que la rupture n'est
pas si ce n'est consommé en tout cas
bien creusé de l'autre côté il y a pas
non plus vraiment de signaux envoyé au
MoDem qui quand même un allié
aujourd'hui plutôt pris en porte à fau
pas très non plus content de la
composition du gouvernement et la
situation sur la loi immigration Horizon
a plus de chance de se sentir heureux du
point de vue du programme mais n'est pas
non plus un groupe qui aujourd'hui est
un groupe qui peut être considéré comme
étant acquis à je dirais une forme
d'euphorie autour du nouveau
gouvernement donc cette majorité déjà
relative est encore plus clivée et donc
vous av un gouvernement qui aujourd'hui
n'apparaît guerre là pour légiférer
d'ailleurs les principales propositions
de Gabriel Attal c'est souvent des
généralisations d'expérimentation voire
des éléments réglementaires la VO
réglementaire évidemment on en parlera
parce que c'est un élément important de
sa stratégie exactement et donc ça
montre que là-dessus on a un
gouvernement qui d'abord s'adresse à une
partie de son électorat électorat en
effet plutôt de centre droit gros focus
sur les classes moyennes et au-delà de
ça bah le Parlement est très secondaire
alors Mathieu vous avez regardé
attentivement suivi les les les les deux
discours le discours de V sénateur 24 he
après celui de l'Assemblée nationale une
version différente oui alors pas de
changement sur le fond hein pas
s'attendre un virage à 180°r quand même
entre hier et aujourd'hui mais en
revanche sur le ton c'était une vraie
déclaration d'amour commencé avec une
citation de Marcel préot qui é un
constitutionnaliste sénateur du dou des
début de la 5e République qui a fait
rosir de plaisir l'hémicycle en France
lorsque le Sénat est faible la
République est faible lorsque le Sénat
est fort la République est forte
lorsqu'il n'y a pas de Sénat il n'y a
pas de République à citer Gabriel Atal
qui a dit qu'il faisait sien les mots de
Marcel prellot et puis en un peu plus
d'une heure de discours le Premier
ministre a multiplié les illades
salement le Sénat comme la chambre de la
réflexion et du long terme celle de la
recherche du compromis nous avons besoin
du Sénat de sa capacité à incarner à la
fois la hauteur de vue et la proximité
avec les Français a dit aussi le premier
ministre qui n'avait que les mots élus
et territoir à la bouche qui a ponctué
son discours en égrainant les noms de
sénateurs présents dans l'émiicle et a
un côté n'en jetez plus autant de
compliments cela dit ça finissait par
faire louche effectivement on se demande
quelles sont ses arrières pensées et ben
évidemment d'abord ce Rabi Baucher avec
une majorité sénatoriale qui a eu le
sentiment de se faire roul dans la
farine quand même par Emmanuel Macron en
décembre ils étaient les rois imposant
leurs vu et leurs textes sur
l'immigration en janvier ils sont
devenus les dindons avec un texte
censuré par le Conseil constitutionnel à
la demande s'il vous plaît du président
h il fallait aussi Gabri se réconcilier
avec le Sénat dans son ensemble j'allais
dire avec l'institution qui se méfie
quand même de cet exécutif qui a failli
le sacrifier le Sénat il y a 5 ans vous
souvenez au lendemain de des gilets
jaunes et pour calmer la colère et puis
en gros qui balance depuis entre la
carotte et le bâton l'exécutif il est au
petit soins quand il a besoin du Sénat
et puis il est carrément directif quand
il le considère comme un simple
supplétif mais surtout Gabriel Atal
comme sa prédécesseur Elisabeth borne B
il a plus que jamais besoin de la
stabilité du Palais du Luxembourg depuis
que c'est le bordel pour reprendre les
mots de Gérald armanin au Palais Bourbon
alors est-ce que cette opération
séduction a
fonctionn pas beaucoup faut faut le dire
en tout cas on l'a fait pas comme ça au
sénateur aussi rapidement il va en
falloir encore car à peine assis Gabriel
Atal a eu le droit à une leçon vous
savez plaire mais savez-vous faire lui a
lancé Bruno retaillot le patron des
sénateur
avant de démolir le bilan du macronisme
même s vérité de l'autre côté de
l'hémicycle che Patrick per caner pardon
le socialiste et puis pas de réforme
sans Sénat a conclu de son côté le
centriste her Marseille en forme
d'avertissement en expliquant que au
piège que tendait le gouvernement sur la
coconstruction en amont vous savez
est-ce qu'on élabore les textes de loi
en amont de les présenter au Parlement
ben lui préférait la construction
classique au Parlement qui permettait
pour le coup de jauger les rapports de
force et puis de pas se faire avoir
après donc du coup on attend de voir ce
que ça va donner parce que trois textes
arrivent qui vont être particulièrement
compliqués hein la
constitutionnalisation de l'IVG on se
souvient que Gérard Larcher a le pied
sur le frein la question de la fin de
vie là on sait que bruneo rotaillot est
deux pieds sur le frein et puis la
décentralisation oui un mot des
relations entre les les premier
ministres et le Sénat parce que c'est
toujours à géométrie mariable et en
fonction des des équilibres politiques
enfin il y a pas de secret on se
souvient de LEONEL Jospin quand il
parlait d'une anomalie parmi les
démocraties bah pourquoi parce que le
Sénat était droite et l'empêchait de
faire ce qu'il voulaitadio oui il est
vrai néanmoins que le S sous la 5e
République n'a jamais été totalement au
cœur du dispositif on se souvient que
des présidents du Sénat ont été opposés
aux différents président de la
République on peut citer àin power
notamment sous François mitteran c'était
très clair puisque l'offensive de la
droite sénatoriale menée par Charles
pascoy a commencé notamment sur les
questions de sécurité en 83 donc le
Sénat était de ce point de vue-là une
chambre tourmentée pour l'exécutif au
demeurant c'est une chambre qui est
assez imprévisible dans le calcul des
votes c'estàdire que les majorités ne
peuvent pas être anticipé par le pouvoir
exécutif il a une dynamique sénatoriale
qui est assez propre pour le
gouvernement actuel ce qui est très
clair c'est que le taux de texte
présenté en première lecture au Sénat
n'a jamais été aussi élevé donc il y a
une volonté très claire de de favoriser
cette première chambre d'autant que
cette majorité relative lui permet en
réalité de préparer l'opinion publique
en quelque sorte à un aspect consensuel
pour rehausser plus encore l'aspect
brouillon politique dans la dans le
mauvais sens du terme de l'Assemblée
nationale donc je pense que Gabriel Atal
va avoir à cœur de soigner des relations
extrêmement courtoises extrêmement
denses extrêmement étroitees avec le le
Sénat mais plus il fera ça plus en
réalité il permettra au Sénat de se
rebiffer et de jouer les enfants gâtés
donc c'est assez terrible de voir que
les relations du point de vue
l'exécutifs n'auront jamais été souhaité
aussi bonnes avec le Sénat et ce qui
paradoxalement détériorera les relations
puisque le Sénat se comportera vraiment
en majesté ouais le le le calendrier
parlementaire même s'il y a des textes
importants à venir il a été relativement
allégé pour les prochains mois Benjamin
Morel est-ce que c'est pour permettre à
Gabriel Atal de de mener la bataille des
élections européennes alors c'est
surtout parce qu'il y a pas de majorité
parce que tout à l'heure vous disiez le
que le Sénat jouit les enfants terribles
en réalité c'est très très classique si
vous voulez lorsque vous avez une
majorité faible à l'Assemblée qu'est-ce
que fait le Sénat et ben il enoie des
scudes surtout si c'est pas la même
majorité qui est au Sénat et à
l'Assemblée nationale lorsque vous
mettez votre texte d'abord au Sénat
l'objectif c'est d'engager LR pour
l'Assemblée nationale qui a envie de
faire LR mettre des petites mines dans
votre texte pour que votre majorité
tombe dessus et boom et donc aujourd'hui
avec une majorité on l'a dit non
seulement relative mais très divisé
imaginez les textes aujourd'hui on parle
par exemple du texte decentralisation on
y reviendra peut-être les associations
d'élus sont en réalité extrêmement
rétisante parce qu'on sait pas
exactement à quoi ressemblera le texte
une fois sorti avec avec la majorité
actuelle à l'Assemblée nationale donc
vous lancez un texte dans le processus
législatif vous ne savez pas comment il
va ressortir vous savez que vous
l'envoyez au Sénat mais vous ne savez
pas comment votre propre majorité va se
diviser sur la version sénatoriale est
ce qu'il restera de votre majorité en
charpie une fois que le texte sera
terminé par ailleurs et bien ce texte en
question il est probable que vous n'en
reconnaissiez même pas réellement la
figure et que vous dites à l'opinion par
exemple sur la loi immigration en fait
je n'en voulais pas vraiment en tout cas
je voulais pas cette version là c'est
très dur à assumer politiquement donc
vous comprenez qu'à ce stadelà envoyer
des choses dans le processus législatif
est très dangereux pour le gouvernement
donc on passe par voie réglementaire
autant que faire se peut pour éviter les
pièges pour éviter les choses trappes
alors évidemment et ça va nous amener à
à parler de l'Ame l'aide médicale d'État
dans un court instant et je sais que Tam
tranui doit être quasiment prête en
salle des conférence mais d'abord une
une question peut-être je reste sur le
l'objectif des des élections européennes
est-ce que dans les dans les enquêtes
que vous faites il y a un petit effet
hatal alors on sait qu'il y a pas de
tête de l Renaissance donc c'est
compliqué à évaluer mais est-ce qu'il y
a un petit effet Atal ou pas du tout sur
les européen non franchement pour
l'instant on voit pas c'est vraiment le
RN qui domine de très très loin et même
je m'interroge moi sur ce virage un
petit peu à droite parce que ce qui
constituait aussi l'électorat d'Emmanuel
Macron ça venait il y avait aussi une
partie des de gens qui venaient de la
gauche et qui peuvent un peu
s'interroger on le voit les députés qui
venaient de la gauche s'interrogent mais
restent dans le rang parce que c'est
compliqué de s'opposer les électeur eux
ils peuvent très bien se dire bah tiens
je vais revenir un peu au berkaille
rapel guusman peut m'intéresser et du
coup les fetatal pour l'instant non on
le mesure pas voire même on peut
s'interroger sur les scores assez bas de
renaissance si c'est pas aussi un effet
de cet électorat qui se déporte oui
c'est même assez curieux qu'ils
choisissent à ce point de virer à droite
avant les européennes alors on comprend
s'ils disent la sensibilité du pays est
plutôt à droite les Français on le voit
plébiscite dans les sondages certaines
réformes étiquetées de droite dur comme
celle sur l'immigration mais le terrain
il est quand même assez occupé pour les
européennes à droite d'un pur point de
vue tactique je ve avec il y a deux
parties d'extrême droite au moins le RN
est reconquête il y a l'lr avec François
béami et donc essayer d'aller gagner des
parts de marché sur ce terrainlà en
lâchant parce que là il l'a lâché tout
l'électorat centre-gauche tous les
socio-démocrates qui avaient voté de
bonne foi entre guillemets pouradame
Macron en 2017 et puis de mauvaise foi
ou un peu contraint et forcé en 2022 eux
vont se reporter comme d'un vote
sanction pour Macron sur raphaë guman
comme si considérait que c'était acquis
ce ce ce vote là qu'il fallait chercher
des voies ailleurs mais il y a peut-être
un danger est-ce que il est vraiment si
acquis est-ce qu'il y en a pas qui vont
partir pour l'instant vous avez pas la
réponse c'est ça frémit un petit peu
dans ce sensl ou pas encore un peu tôt
franchement faudrait savoir un peu quels
sont les reports voit moi j'aime
beaucoup quand les sondeurs sont
prudents et ne s'engagent pas trop tôt
avant une élection l'aide médicale
d'État on va en parler tout de suite
parce que c'est intéressant quand on
fait le comparatif des deux discours de
de politique générale hier à l'Assemblée
aujourd'hui au Sénat hier à l'Assemblée
il a il a clairement parlé de la voix
réglementaire et ça a provoqué cette
réaction d'écti le président du parti LR
les républicains il y avait un
engagement de porter la nécessité porter
un texte législatif sur laame donc c'est
une diversion c'est le non respect d'un
engagement qui avait été pris euh devant
nous devant la représentation nationale
c'est une forme de trahison de la parole
donnée sur
l'ame et comme promis on rejoint en
direct Tam tranui en salle des
conférences ici au au Sénat un premier
ministre très attendu par la droite
sénatoriale sur cette ame oui l'ame qui
finalement a été un sujet à peine
esquissé cet après-midi à la différence
de ce qui a été fait à l'Assemblée
nationale pourquoi et bien tout
simplement parce que et bien la réforme
de l'Ame c'est un sujet qui fâche avec
la droite et qui fche donc avec la
majorité sénatoriale pour bien tout
comprendre il faut revenir quelques
semaines en arrière au mois de décembre
lors des négociations sur la loi
immigration la droite et notamment la
droite sénatoriale réclame au
gouvernement un engagement ferme pour
réformer l'aide médicale d'État ce
dispositif qui permet aux étrangers en
situation irrégulière d'avoir accès aux
soins et que la droite veut fortement
restreindre ellisabeth borne s'y engage
dans un courrier à Gérard Larcher et
depuis et bien le Premier ministre a
changé Gabriel hatal a annoncé que la
réforme se ferait bien qu'elle se ferait
par voie réglementaire et cela avant
l'été or vous avez entendu Erric soioti
qui a estimé que c'était une trahison de
la parole donnée tout à l'heure Bruno
retaillot qui a à nouveau lui pesté sur
le fait que l'on passait par-dessus le
Parlement alors si on regarde tout de
même he ce courrier du mois de décembre
d'Élisabeth borne et bien la première
ministre d'allor avait pris soin de
mentionner que la réforme de l'Ame
pouvait se faire par voie réglementaire
ou par voie législative
elle avait également écrit que les
parlementaires seraient associés mais
sans plus de détails elle disait aussi
s'appuyer sur le rapport Evin stéepanini
comme Gabriel hatal l'a répété lui cette
semaine mais les LR vous l'avez compris
n'en font pas du tout la même lecture
c'est Don bien la preuve que les
promesses n'engagent que ceux qui les
écoutent et que l'écoute elle est
parfois sélective elle n'est pas la même
des deux côtés
ce point en tout cas et bien la droite
vous l'avez compris elle en fait un
sujet de discorde mais pour le reste et
bien le discours de Gabriel hatal cet
après-midi a tout de même marqué des
points chez certains alliés de la droite
sénatoriale on a entendu notamment les
discours assez constructifs du groupe
Union centriste du groupe Les
Indépendants Hervé Marseille et Claude
maluret merci beaucoup Tam tranui pour
toutes ces ces informations faut dire
quand même que que Elisabeth borne a
payé deux fois pour voir que les LR
n'était pas des partenaires fiables à
l'Assemblée nationale flent V donc on va
pas donner tort à Gabriel Atal de de de
de plonger ou de replonger non ah c'est
le moins qu'on puisse dire c'estàd que
il a été largement enseigné par le
chemin de croix d'Élisabeth band de ce
point de vue-là donc il a raison de
choisir la voie réglementaire pour pour
laame alors je pense que c'est pas
encore fait d'abord parce qu'il y a
aussi certains sénateurs qui annoncent
une proposition de loi reprenant les
articles qui ont été censurés par le
Conseil constitutionnel donc voyons voir
ce que la mariée va mettre dans le
panier en l'espèce pour voir voir s'il y
a une capacité de troc quand à l'option
de la voir règlementaire je je je
j'apprends que la Constitution est à si
facile d'usage on bascule un sujet qui
est quand même je pense éminemment
législatif dans la voie
réglementaire je pense que je serait une
association de défense des libertés
fondamentales ou une association d'aide
aux migrants j'auris de beaux CADES
contentieux devant le Conseil d'État à à
à à mettre en œuvre donc je pense qu'il
faut être très prudent sur ce genre de
promesse parce que elle elle n'engage
aussi que ceux qui les écoutent ou votre
avis làdessus Benjam bah c'est
évidemment un marché de DUP c'est-à-dire
que en effet on fait pas la même chose
par voie réglementaire qu'on ne le fait
par voie législative alors les LR
avaient probablement des grandes
ambitions en la matière ce sera si
jamais on passe par la voie
réglementaire réduit à pot de chagrin
ensuite bah la victoire politique quand
vous faites voter une loi quand vous
l'imposez au gouvernement quoi qu'il
arrive quoi qu'il y est dedans c'est
cocorico là si c'est un décret
évidemment les LR ne pourront pas
s'inventter par ailleurs après la
censure du Conseil constitutionnel vous
comprenez bien que la me était un sujet
parmi d'autres et que ce qui était
demandé par les LR c'était pas seulement
une réforme de laame mais une reprise de
l'ensemble des dispositions censurées ce
que ne permettra pas de faire le texte
en question donc c'est plutôt malin de
la part du gouvernement sauf sauf si on
considère que bah ils ont besoin encore
de LR à l'Assemblée et au Sénat au quel
cas entre ça et Rachid hadti ça fait un
début d'année chargé ouis Mathieu il y a
il y a ce volontarisme qui qui est
peut-être l'une des marques de fabrique
de de Gabriel Attal ce volontaris se
heurte là petit à petit au mur de au mur
de la réalité c'estd que comme la
situation politique n'a pas changé il y
a bien un moment où il y a un moment où
le réel c'est que quand on se cogne
comme disait lacord voilà et là il va se
cogn très vite il s'est cogné déjà avec
les agriculteurs il a perdu avec les
agriculteurs un de ses atouts ce qu'on
parlait de de paroes performatives
c'est-à-dire jeudi et c'est fait et et
là pour le coup il a parlé vendredi ça
n'a pas suffit à éteindre le mouvement
il a parlé dimanche ça n'a pas suffit à
éteindre le mouvement il a parlé mardi
maintenant les agriculteurs sont à
uniste il y a un petit côté la méthode
àale entre guillemets qui qui qui est
mise en doute alors après c'est une
surface projective Gabriel Atal il tient
un discours de droite à ses
conservateurs mais lui il a plutôt les
habits du progressisme il est jeune il a
dit hier ouvertement
Hel an donc sociétalement enfin il va il
va porter la fin de vie il va porter
l'inscription de Liv la Constitution il
y a encore ce yatus et je suis pas
certain que l'opinion n bien les bien
encore identifié on verra on verra au
fur et à mesure mais ce qui est sûr
c'est que là il se heurte à un vrai
conflit qui va être particulièrement
difficile à déminer on a beaucoup parlé
sur ce plateau le le le conflit avec les
agriculteurs parce que il faut à la fois
faire de la politique quasiment
politicienne négocier avec les syndicats
en l'occurrence la FNSEA et puis en même
temps essayer d'éteindre un mouvement
revendication disparate et puis c'est
vrai que la réalité et ben c'est qu'il
faut mettre les mains dans le campoui il
a une pas une très grande expérience du
Parlement Gabriel Atal il a été un petit
peu député et puis assez vite ministre
il faut tisser des des des des majorités
nouer des liens alors il a pour lui sa
courtoisie qui fait qu'il est plutôt
respecté dans chacun des camps c'est pas
c'est pas une figure du macronisme qui
est hie par ses adversaires qu'il soit à
gauche ou à droite et donc peut-être que
cette personnalité là peut mettre de
l'huile dans les rouages mais au bout du
bout faut quand même parler politique et
il faut faire passer des textes et ça
pour trouver des alliés c'est pas le
moment alors on va reparler de de la
crise agricole de la colère des
agriculteurs dans dans un instant mais
mais je reste sur le les relations avec
le parti LR que ce soit ici au Sénat ou
à l'Assemblée nationale et alors ça va
se jouer au Sénat notamment sur le texte
de constitutionnalisation de
l'interruption volontaire de grossesse
on écoute un extrait du discours de
politique générale de Gabriel Atal cet
après-midi ici au
Sénat hier dans un vote qui a dépassé
l'éclivage l'Assemblée nationale a
adopter un projet de loi constitutionnel
pour inscrire la liberté de recourir à
l'interruption volontaire de grossesse
dans la
Constitution alors que les droits des
femmes sont toujours les premiers remis
en cause je suis intimement convaincu
qu'inscrire cette liberté dans la
Constitution est une protection
nécessaire vous avez déjà réussi à
travailler ensemble Assemblée nationale
et Sénat autour d'une rédaction commune
je suis sûr que vous y parviendrez à
nouveau enfin nos valeurs c'est
permettre à chacun de mourir dans la
dignité aujourd'hui le constat de
beaucoup de malades de beaucoup de
familles de beaucoup de Français et
pressant nous devons entendre leur appel
à y répondre avec vous avec gravité
prudence et dans le respect des
convictions de chacune et de
chacun alors sur la
constitutionnalisation de l'interruption
volontaire de grossess madame alemel on
a eu il y a quelques jours la
déclaration du président du Sénat Gérard
Larcher et puis cet après-midi celle de
Bruno rotaillot sur sur notre
antenne on on voit bien que la la la
ligne est plutôt à la à l'opposition à à
ce texte la ligne est plutôt à
l'opposition alors il y a deux sujets de
fond il y a un sujet comment est-ce
qu'on Palise qu'est-ce qu'on met dedans
et là il y a quand même des aujourd'hui
des je dirais des inquiétudes au Sénat
sur ce que pourrait faire le Conseil
constitutionnel d'un droit àég dans la
Constitution vous savez la cour
allemande de Carl étaé jusqu'à prévoir
le délai entre la consultation d'un
médecin et la réalisation de l'acte dans
sa jurisprudence qui plus en se basant
sur une close d'éternité vous pouvez pas
toucher à ça en Allemagne sans mettre à
la poubelle la Constitution donc ça
malgré tout ce sont des choses qui
marquent aujourd'hui au sein de la
droite française attention le
gouvernement des juges et cetera ne
constitutionnalisons pas à tour de bras
c'était déjà une position qui avait
induit le débat qu'on avait eu droit
liberté sur la question de l'IVG
lorsquil y avait eu la première navette
entre San
mais à l'époque le Sénat s'était pas
opposé au principe et alors qu'il y
avait un certain nombre de gardes defous
qui fléchaient vers le Parlement après
il y a un certain nombre de mauvaises
manières du Gouvernement sur ce sujet
notamment en disant attention regardez
le 5 mars ça y est on va
constitutionnaliser ce qui signifie ben
que la navette que droit signatorial il
y a pas vraiment de sens donc on a une
opposition aujourd'hui de principe qui
m' paraît peut-être être plus de
principe que de fond ça veut pas dire
queun fois que le texte sera arrivé
qu'on l'aura modifié un petit peu juste
pour embêter le gouvernement pour qu'il
revienne à l'Assemblée et qu'il
reviendra une dernière fois au Sénat il
y aura pas la réunion d'un congrès
possible mais ce sera clairement pas le
5 mars s'il a lieu Florent vadiillot le
le le le texte qu'il avait été voté une
première fois au Sénat avec une
initiative de Philippe B Ava peut-être
surpris certains sénateurs
LR ils vont revenir en arrière d'après
vous comment on peut imaginer le ce ce
ce débat dans les prochains jours je
trouve que pour l'instant ils mettent
une épée dans le dos du gouvernement
pour montrer que d'autres révisions
constitutionnelles vont être très
compliqué en e pour une révision
constitutionnelle deuxièm effectivement
pour répondre au mauvaise manière du
gouvernement parce qu'es on elles sont
quand même plutôt multiplié en l'espèce
ils sont plutôt acculés que associés
dans ce dispositif donc il y a une
réaction
d'humeur ça sera je pense la campagne
des européennes sera pas neutre en
l'espèce parce que ça sera une vraie
thématique de campagne à voir s'ils
assument le rejet de la
constitutionalisation de l'IVG comme un
élément en fait d'une culture politique
ce qui n'est pas impossible je rappelle
que que François Xavier béami euh ses
positions étaient extrêmement claires il
a juste mis un mouchoir dans sa poche
mais pas de l'eau dans son vin donc il a
il y a une vraie marge de manœuvre le
rassemblement national est extrêmement
divisé sur sur ce dispositif là 14 12 à
l'Assemblée nationale donc je pense que
il y a encore une incertitude sur la
stratégie politique qui va être adoptée
sur ce dispositif là et donc il y a
beaucoup de politiques qui qui va qui va
se se nouer après il faut pas oublier
quand même que les républicains ont
peut-être aussi envie de pointer
l'hypocrisie du gouvernement parce que
cette constitutionnalisation certes sous
une formule différente elle avait déjà
été proposée par la gauche elle avait
été refusé en 2018 et aujourd'hui pour
en quelque sorte socialiser son image on
en fait un grand combat alors qu'il a
été mis sous le Boissau pendant très
longtemps donc il y a il y a cette
volonté aussi de faire sortir du bois la
macronie qui est un peu hypocrite sur ce
dispositif alors je je je ne sous-estime
pas l'importance d'un texte sur euh la
fin de vie évidemment ou la
constitutionnalisation de l'IVG mais
quand même Christel crappel dans ce
calendrier parlementaire à venir il y a
moins de texte ou de réformes très
attendu par par l'opinion on peut dire
ça Quême non et puis c'est vrai que sur
ce sujet là c'est un sujet qui alors qui
est pas totalement consensuel he il y a
des frangches de l'opinion qui sont
contre mais qui pose pas tellement de de
questions ni sur la fin de vie pareil il
y aura sans doute des débats mais dans
nos enquêtes voilà les gens sont plutôt
pour en revanche le sentiment que ça
peut donner c'est qu'effectivement c'est
pas très lisible on comprend pas
forcément pourquoi ça arrive maintenant
et le côté on socialise on enfin on
donne une couleur un peu plus à gauche
pas sûr que ce soit vraiment perçu dans
l'opinion et à l'invers ça peut donner
le sujet le sentiment que c'est encore
un sujet de discorde encore un sujet où
le Parlement arrive pas à se mettre
d'accord et du coup renforcer ce
sentiment de totale paralysie et qu'on
arrive pas vraiment à à avancer et il
faut le dire que les préoccupations
restent quand même très focalisées sur
des sujets socio-économiqu donc les
attentes des Français restent quand même
autour du pouvoir d'achat et moins sur
Cees sujetslou mais alors justement si
on reprend la la les deux discours de de
politique générale je reste avec vous
Christelle cppelet de de de Gabriel Atal
il y a quand même beaucoup de mesures
très pointilliste et qui répondent à des
à des à des questions si je prends la
santé par exemple paiement des
rendez-vous médicaux non honoré psy
mieux remboursé pour les ados
régularisation ou recrutement de
médecins étrangers on est allé très très
loin dans le dans le détail c'est quoi
c'est c'est vraiment la méthode Atal
c'estàdire je prends une difficulté
auxquell sont à laquelle sont confronté
les Français j'y réponds comment vous
l'analysez ça B je trouve ça
relativement habile d'un point de vue
opinion parce que un ça donne le
sentiment que c'est concret et c'est
quand même ce qu'on reproche au politiqu
de pas l'être et de ça parle quand même
aux gens les rendez-vous médicaux on
voit c'estez bien on voit asse bien ce
que c'est c'est une façon de se faire
entendre de Français
qui et d'ailleurs c'est repris dans les
médias on parle beaucoup de faire payer
les rendez-vous non honorés donc voilà
c'est quelque chose qui va marquer dans
l'opinion à l'éducation nationale c'est
ce qui a fonctionné il a eu une mesure
sur la BAA une mesure sur le harcèlement
ça a fonctionné après l'inconvénient
c'est que ça peut paraître relativement
anecdotique et pas résoudre derrière les
grands problèmes de fond ils sont en
train de tuer le métier en fait le
président fait le boulot du Premier
ministre le Premier ministre fait le
boulot des ministres et labaya prisement
il était ministre il était pas Premier
ministre c'est plutôt de à l'échelon
ministérielle que se décide ce genre de
mesure qu'est-ce que vont annoncer ces
ministres onâ de regarder ou Benj Morel
ça permet on en revient à la question de
la voie législative ou de la voie
réglementaire il y a beaucoup de ces de
ces mesures ont été annoncé qui peuvent
passer qu'on pe forcément besoin d'une
loi quoi c'est là que c'est très habile
c'est-à-dire que en fait c'est très
marquant dans l'opinion ça paraît très
concernant ce sont des symboles qui et
ben britment le débat public en même
temps ça passe par voix réglementaire et
la plupart du temps ça coûte rien or les
deux problèmes c'est que il y a pas de
majorité à l'Assemblée il y a pas de
sous donc à partir de là c'est plutôt
intelligent si vous voulez la seule
difficulté par rapport à ça c'est que
lorsque vous votez une loi et bien on en
parle pendant 2 semaines 3 semaines
lorsque vous faites paraître un décret
on en parle pendant une 1h 2h donc il va
falloir tenir avec tout ça jusqu'aux
européennes en égrainant la chose en le
mettant en récit et en communiquant
dessus Gabriel àal a la réputation
d'être un bon communicant et ben il va
falloir justement que là-dessus il
communique et que la communication
accompagne des actes qui en eux-même
s'il passait uniquement au j ça ferait
pas beaucoup de bruit ouais encore
faut-il euh sortir de la colère de la
crise de des agriculteurs en France mais
aussi en Europe un témoignage après les
annonces d'hier discours de politique
générale à l'Assemblée nationale celui
de cet agriculteur de lesson on l'
retrouvé sur un barrage
regardez en ayant dit qu'il mettait
l'agriculture a-dessus de tout on
s'attendait à quand même quelques
quelques annonces un peu marquantes pour
l'instant on a rien entendu donc bon je
sais pas combien de temps ça va durer
peut-être que il y aura des annonces
supplémentaires mais pour l'instant on
n'est pas satisfait en tout cas on peut
tenir le temps qu'il faudra en fait ici
on est bien approvisionné on est on est
bien organisé le le camp de base est
assez bien structuré peut tenir la nuit
le jour on est réapprovisionné tous les
jours en pain en nourriture donc en fait
on peut tenir longtemps j' vis qu'on
parle un peu de stratégie
gouvernementale face à face à une crise
sociale comme celle-là Florent vadiillo
parce que gabrielel a déjà beaucoup
donné lâché annoncé qu'est-ce qu'il peut
faire de plus maintenant alors d'abord
il a beaucoup annoncé de choses qui
étaient déjà dans les tuyaux la prime
d'arrachage par exemple il y a une
petite rallonge mais elle était déjà
prévu
ensuite il l' sur le GNR c'est pas le
cas non c'est pas le cas et ensuite il y
a beaucoup de discussions qu'il a
reporté au niveau européen parce que on
est quand même dans une dynamique de
politique agricole commune moi je pense
que sur cette sur ce dossier-là très
précis qui en fait s'impose à lui plus
qu'il n'est allé le chercher Gabriel
Attal il peut tomber sur un vrai piège
parce que si on regarde sa trajectoire
politique et la stratégie qu'il a
déployé jusqu'à présent il a toujours
choisi ses dossiers sa temporalité et il
n'a jamais été confronté à leur mise en
œuvre il y y a pas un dossier sur lequel
il a été est jamais resté assez
longtemps non jamais resté assez
longtemps donc sur celui-ci non
seulement le dossier s'impose à lui il
est sommé de devoir aller vite pour
transformer la réalité il n'en a ni les
moyens législatifs ni les moyens
financiers et même pas les moyens
administratifs parce que on on ne met
pas on ne change pas une politique
agricole en un claquement de doigts et
donc cette parole performative qui l'a
mise en scène et qui l'a pour en quelque
sorte imprimé comme méthode atale elle
risque de se heurter sur le mur de la
réalité et d'ors et déjà puisque il a
dit qu'il voulait être concret et rapide
les agriculteurs qui sont loin d'être
bêtes il demandent des des des des des
exemples très précis et concrets de ce
qu'il va mettre en œuvre or pour
l'instant ça n'est pas le cas alors il y
a quand même il y a il y a de l'argent
pour les viticulteurs plusieurs dizaines
de millions d'euros il y a euh euh les
l'argent de la pack qui avait pas été
versé qui sera verersé avant le 31 mars
enfin ça c'est c'est concret d'ailleurs
vous vous dites il a on a jamais eu le
temps de voir les effets de ce qu'il
avait fait
si on prend la baaya on a pu se rendre
compte assez vite que ce qu' avait
demandé les les directeurs
d'établissement finalement ça leur
retirait une épine pied donc c'est pas
tout à fait vrai quand même ce que vous
disiez il y a eu 200 cas d'abaya qui se
sont présentés ça ça a pas créé un
monstre peut-être faut-il s'interroger
sur l'acuité du problème lui-même mais
c'est un autre débat non mais les
agriculteurs pardon de le dire c'est une
des professions qui est d'abord très
organisée qui connaît extrêmement bien
la mécanique de versement des aides des
problématiques administratives donc ils
savent pertinemment que ce qui est
annoncé là nécessite de des mises en
œuvre extrêmement complexes et et longue
donc on si je suis un peu trivial on ne
l'aura fait pas oui d'accord chrisel
crappel ce gouvernement et peut-être
gabrielal particulièrement est attendu
sur les questions d'ordre et d'autorité
l'autorité c'est quand même quelque
chose que Gabriel Atal porte notamment
depuis qu'il a été ministre de
l'éducation nationale sauf que là
l'autorité elle est ils ont commencé par
dire on va on va laisser faire les
agriculteurs vous voyez ce que je veux
dire oui il peut y
avoir se fracasser sur sur le sur cette
crise VO là il a un peu j l'opinion
aussi hein comme il sait que le
mouvement est très populaire que les
Français a une très bonne image des
agriculteurs voilà faire preuve d'un peu
de bienveillance certes c'est paradoxal
mais ça il risquait pas grand-chose de
l'ampignon là où il risque effectivement
plus c'est si se heurte effectivement à
la réalité et au sentiment que son
volontarisme affiché ben finalement ne
se traduit pas concrètement par des
mesures qui font c le mouement si R s
bloqué dans 48 he il y il y a plus rien
dans les magasins là ça ça va leetomber
cet après-midi à ringist il y avait le
président de la Chambre d'agriculture du
Lot Garon donc un département tout a
commencé qui est Coordination Rurale
donc qui est arrive à r malgré toutes
les interdiction son premier CR c'était
qui c'est qui commande ou en parlant de
lui-même c'est
comme l'autorité d'un Premier ministre
qui a laissé s'installer voilà et qui a
laissé s'installer ce conflit en tout
cas qui n'a pas su le déminer et c'est
pas c'est pas facile c'est pas il sagit
pas de donner le son voilà elle est déjà
contestée ça fragilise fondamentalement
parce que en effet il plus il peut pas
agir sur le réel or le souffle et cetera
lesffetatal c'était justement de pouvoir
agir or là on voit qu'il est en grande
partie impuissant c'est une situation
qui est difficile pour un gouvernement
parce que je dirais le triptique des
enfers est réuni d'un côté vous n'avez
pas d'interlocuteurs aujourd'hui fiable
parce que les syndicats sont en
concurrence en vue des élections dans
les chambres agricoles et que qui plus
est ils sont dépassés par leur base donc
à partir de là c'est compliqué de
négocier certains ont peut-être quelques
arrière-pensé politique et il y a
quelques arrière-pensées probablement de
l'autre côté vous avez une opinion
contre vous 9 Français sur 10 qui son
soutien le mouvement je parle sous votre
contrôle 8/ 10 qui semble soutenir les
blocages et on peut dire oui mais ils se
retourneront la réalité c'est que si
demain je peux pas manger mon biftech
est-ce que c'est de la faute du
gouvernement ou est-ce que c'est de la
faute des agriculteurs moi je pense
qu'il se retourneront contre gerérald
daranin qui qui a été trop laxiste au
début du du mouvement alors trop laxiste
ou contre le gouvernement qui ne répond
pas aux revendications et de l'autre
côté les vrais leviers pour calmer la
colère agricole aujourd'hui il sont pas
nationaux ils sont essentiellement
européens et donc à partir de là la
commission l'a d'ailleurs dit on peut
agir un peu rapidement sur les ch mais
sinon le processus législatif européen
ça prend du temps donc vous avez une
crise dans lequel vous n'êtes pas
populaire et des manettes qui ne sont
pas à vous pour arriver à régler le
problème et ben évidemment c'est pas
quoi c'est pas facile oui mouvement d'
est européen on l'a dit FL radio et qui
va alors peut-être pas mais qui pourrait
se régler en partie au Conseil européen
ce soir et et demain à Bruxelles non il
y aura une prise de position du Conseil
européen mais il y aura pas de il y aura
pas de mesures il y aura même pas de
plan d'urgence mis en place c'est c'est
des montants qui sont tell ement
structurel pour l'Union européenne
tellement colossaux je vois pas le
Conseil européen arriver à se mettre
d'accord sur ce dispositif là alors même
en plus malgré l'opposition parce que là
il moratoire sur la ça coûte pas cher
oui le moratoire sur la mais je me
permets quand même de signaler que dans
le cadre de la campagne pour les
européennes la question de l'adhésion de
l'Ukraine à l'Union européenne se pose
or c'est un élément de distorsion majeur
pour la politique agricole commune donc
je vois pas les membres du Conseil
européen arriver à se mettre d'accord y
compris dans l'optique d'envisager
intégration de l'uchrainee à l'Union
européenne sur les questions agricoles
vraiment je pense que le dossier est
beaucoup plus épineux et beaucoup plus
difficile à mettre en œuvre merci
beaucoup merci à tous d'avoir participé
à ce débat Benjamin Morel la France en
miette c'est votre livre qui est publié
aux éditions du SER à très bientôt sur
sur notre antenne